[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
he's chris manick sports illustrated
senior writer former
nba ball boy for the boston celtics and
it's great to have chris back on was
anybody ever mean
to you as a ball boy like a player or
coach
uh two jump to mind uh reggie miller i
think i've said this
on your show before uh and john koncak
remember him
from back in the day atlanta atlanta
then
detroit yeah yeah like kind of mean that
kind of stuff sticks out to a teenager
but what what happened here like why why
would they
be mean to you i i think koncak was just
in a bad mood at one point and threw a
ball at me that hit me in the head
and reggie if i'm not mistaken like i
was working
behind the bench and working behind the
bench you kind of
have the water cup and you you dip it
over their shoulder to see if they want
it
and reggie just turned around and
whacked it away and it got kind of all
over me
in that moment it was a tough moment for
reggie i will say this about reggie
miller
though um when you worked locker rooms
the reggie miller bag was an actual
thing like he always wanted
one of the locker room guys to take his
bag and walk it like the
30 feet down to the bus and he would
give you like fifty dollars for it and
fifty dollars in the late 90s to a kid
in college
you're spending that in some good places
dan so i'll give reggie that much who is
the best tipper
oh man antoine walker was an excellent
tipper
uh yeah maybe too much he doesn't have
any money potentially potentially
uh mark jackson was a really good tipper
when he and reggie played together
it was always good to kind of huddle
around them to see if you can get their
bag i mean i've
i've told this story many times before
but allen iverson was
was a good tipper uh when alan wanted
uh you know his coronas or whatever he
wanted he made sure that
you know we got taken care of to take
care of that for him so
most guys i would say were excellent
tippers all right let me dive into the
issues here
uh let me start with james harden based
off his comments last night it almost
felt like an
exit interview there that hey i've done
everything i can do and this is a mess
and
uh hey see you later uh where
where do the rockets go from from here
i mean i think you first have to put out
uh point out
that james harden made the mess and he
created
this situation that the rockets are in
right now now maybe there would have
been growing pains
regardless if you trade for a starting
point guard in john wall who doesn't
play the first couple of games
uh you're gonna have to acclimate to a
new backcourt mate christian wood
is a new player in that mix but it's
extremely
clear that james harden and his
unwillingness to buy in
as wall alluded to last night is a part
of this problem i mean you see him
i mean nba tv dan is making cracks at
his weight
like you know you've you've kind of gone
to a different level when nba tv feels
comfortable
uh taking shots at your physique so
that's a big part of it as well now
you ask where the rockets go from here
my understanding in the last couple of
days still
is that the rockets are determined to be
patient with this
because they believe that the longer
they play this thing out
the more teams will materialize as
prospective suitors
and that will allow them to get into a
bidding war for james harden they could
pull the trigger on a deal for harden
right now there are multiple offers
that are on the table for him but they
believe that they can maximize his value
by holding on to him throughout january
into february and towards that march
deadline
i i think they've only played nine games
and that's what i don't understand he's
got new faces
in there and i don't know why he doesn't
want to give it
unless he just says look i love the city
of houston
uh and the strip clubs but i don't want
to play for the rockets get me out of
here
even though he's not giving this a
chance with john wall boogie cousins and
christian wood
which to me is surprising because you
would have thought
james harden would at least say let me
see what we have maybe we have something
unique here different here i don't know
these guys have been quality players
that's what's a little bit surprising is
he's basically
uh you know pulling up stakes after nine
games
i agree i would have given john wall
half a chance because
you know we talk a lot about kevin
durant's recovery from achilles
surgery john wall has been just as good
i mean at least as far as his recovery
goes
and looks like he's bounced all the way
back physically
from that injury cousins kind of is what
he is at this stage of his career after
his injuries but wood
is kind of an ideal type of player at
least offensively
to play off of james harden play in the
pick and roll run the floor
i mean there's a chance for this team if
they all bought in
to compete pretty hard for a top four or
five seed in the western conference and
from there you never know what's gonna
happen i mean
you know the clippers have fallen on
their face you know recently in the
playoffs the lakers
they look like the best team right now
but they could be one injury away
from scuffling i mean the rockets are
not bad enough
that you know declaring this team
unfixable
makes any kind of sense at this point of
the season we'll get to kyrie
in that issue in a moment here do you
agree with you know i'm watching the
lakers
and lebron's played in every game but
he's playing a career low 32 minutes it
feels like there is
load management during games not taking
nights off
do you sense this a little bit i mean
you know as any coach will tell you it's
difficult to get lebron
to bring his minutes down he wants to
play in every game he wants to play
as many minutes as possible and the
numbers reflect that he's usually got in
his way but
this is exactly what the lakers need to
be doing keeping those minutes
in the low 30s kind of the way that
milwaukee's treated giannis
over the last few years of his career if
you do that you don't necessarily need
to
to give him too many nights off and i'm
sure there will be nights he'll take off
in the weeks and months ahead they're
just too many three and four nights
back to backs a lot of weird situations
because of the schedule that undoubtedly
are only going to get weirder because of
these postponements but
if you can keep lebron in the early 30s
and minutes
nothing guarantees anything i guess but
it gets as close as you can be to making
sure that he's
fully fresh in the playoffs feels like
the sports media might be waking up
today or this week and going oh wow
there's covet issues going on
because we've been dealing with the nfl
college football
the nba has been dealing with this that
they survived orlando but now this is
reality here
college basketball the same thing so
where
you know where's the nba going to be
headed to kind of protect itself
in this you know the especially in los
angeles you know with you know the covet
issues there
yeah i mean the nba says they've
expected this they anticipated this but
i don't believe they expected this much
and this many issues
this early in the season where are they
headed
they're going to push forward dan it's
it's just as simple as that they
are determined to get as close to 72
games in
on this schedule they are determined to
get this season over by early july
before the olympics
and there is hope amongst the league
executives that i've talked to in the
last 48 hours
that these enhanced protocols are going
to help
now the league it has a coveted problem
especially when it comes to teams like
dallas which now has a recent run
of covet positive players but more than
anything
it has a close contact problem that's
what's wreaking havoc
amongst teams in this league with their
rosters
one guy goes out with kovid but then
four or five other guys have to go out
because they were in close contact
with that player that's at the crux of
the changes
the league made in the last 24 hours
where they said look when you're at home
you got to stay in your house when
you're on the road no more approved
restaurants
no more friends in hotel rooms they're
going to do everything they can
to limit the interactions of players as
best as possible and the union's on
board with this i mean everything the
league has done
has had to be collectively bargained
with the union and michelle roberts and
the union brass
are on board with this strategy because
they know it can't continue like this so
the only way to ensure
that not only are these games played but
they're played at a high level where
you're not just having eight guys out
there
struggling to to get through a game the
only way to make sure that happens
is to severely restrict player movements
in
the most significant way outside of a
bubble atlanta at phoenix has just been
postponed
that the suns couldn't come up with uh
the the
tracing yeah the required number of
players by the way plenty of room on the
lamello ball bandwagon if you would like
to get
like oh no no no no no no no no no who
called the mellow ball
in print for rookie of the year before
the season this guy
i did all in on the metal ball bandwagon
i know
how about in a medium that people
actually are going to be able to see
you know and hear like it's in print and
online what do you want me to do scream
it from the top of mount snow
you should have said i want to be on
your show
i want to scream from the mountaintops i
got one thing to say
we could have been there together we
could have been there together
i'm still not entirely sure i didn't say
it but everything you save
are things that i get wrong so i don't
we can work
together on the project if you'd like to
okay
timelines maybe a little off there but
i'll give you a little bit of credit
there
you know maybe look hey i watched a lot
i thought lamela ball
was one of the most over scrutinized
players coming into the draft i mean
everyone was kind of focused on the fact
that
he didn't finish the season lithuania
then overseas he didn't finish the
season
uh in new zealand like he just he had so
many problems
and i said that a week before you said
it
well i okay i didn't hear you say that
i've just been
i've i believe this kid has a lot of
talent i think he is a
incredible playmaker and on that team
with the firepower they kind of have
with hayward and terry rozier
and graham like that's a recipe for you
know being a double double type of guy
every single night so i think he's
really good i i agree
you know the shot's going to be an issue
but he's fun to watch
he needs shots shots are issues for
everybody dad i mean just give him a
couple of years
somebody will rework his shot and it
will get better i mean
there's too many shot doctors in the nba
right now for for that to be a lingering
issue towards his uh is a sense
all right i have held off long enough
kyrie irving situation here
help me understand because i've been
told by two people that i trust you got
to be
you know make sure you're sensitive here
you don't want to be uh
you're not sensitive in a situation like
this on your show and i go okay
tell me what to be sensitive about with
kyrie irving what am i missing here with
kyrie irving
well it's still unclear about
exactly why he's away from the team then
that's no
the nets know why he's away i don't
think that was
abundantly clear to them very early on
you heard steve nash say in his first
press avail
when kyrie disappeared that he didn't
really know where kyrie was but
they know now and kyrie's teammates as a
result of text conversations with them
they're aware of the situation right now
i can't say i know
definitively dan so i don't want to
speculate too much on a guy being away
for personal reasons but one thing i can
tell you
is that the nets are going to continue
to handle this situation with kid gloves
not because they're empathetic with
kyrie irving necessarily though i'm sure
they are
on some level they just know that he's
the key to them winning a championship
so they're not going to sabotage their
season
by uh getting a little overworked up
about something that's going on
in the month of january the thing you
have to watch though
is the impact this has on kevin durant
kevin durant could have gone anywhere
he could have signed with any team in
the league he chose brooklyn
and kyrie irving he thought because of
his friendship with kyrie irving
that they would be an ideal pair kevin
durant's not saying much
right now but what i'm wondering and
i've heard this from other people across
the league is
how long does that last how long does
kevin durant say look
i'm playing like an mvp right now i'm
all the way back for my injury i need
you
to get back here and help me out we've
got chemistry issues to figure out
with new teammates we've got to work
stuff out between each other
on the floor what i'm watching is durant
and look this is gonna be a process
because
now that that video was out there this
is out of kyrie's hands and it's out of
the net's hands
for when he can return if the nba
determines that that video
was authentic for this week as it
appears to be at a birthday he's gonna
have to go into some protocols he's
gonna have to yeah the video at the
birthday party
he's gonna have to go into some
protocols that will keep him out for
another week if not longer
so wait was he in a zoom call last night
that had to do with politics with the
district attorney and he was under the
name
cal irving i think it was kai
oh k-a-i okay i think okay i saw that
malik andrews tweeted that out
that was i mean this is like it's gonna
be like
it's gonna be like a where's waldo
situation for a while where kyrie pops
up everywhere
but at the nets practice facility okay
but he's this is during the nets game
last night
he's on a zoom call help me
i wish i could dan i i don't fully
understand
the situation um all i've been told is
the nets are
aware of exactly what's going on but
they have no idea
when he's coming back and look you can
tell from
some of the public statements that have
been made that the nets are starting to
get
a little bit you know tired of some of
this i mean steve nash saying
kyrie will have an opportunity to
explain it when he comes back the
statement issued
by sean marx the general manager saying
kyrie was saying basically the same
thing
that kyrie will have a chance to explain
it i mean they they understand
everything i just said
that they need kyrie back on the floor
to start developing chemistry with a
team that's been
kind of been consistent i mean their
defense has been really bad their
offense
is is durant their rotations are all
over the place right now
under steve nash they've got to start
developing some chemistry in the season
if they hope to have a chance to win a
championship in a couple of months
good to talk to you as always chris
thanks for joining us you got it dan
that's uh chris mannix
he's all in on lamello ball